morale makes up three quarters of the
game in combat you know your football
team against another football team and
they have great morale but you guys are
better players yeah right well it's
probably not going to work out too well
but because this is what i was thinking
about last night i was like well you
know where is that going to really carry
you in a football game
but then i thought what if you what if
your football game was played for months
you see what i'm saying yeah and it
wasn't about how big and strong you were
but it was about hey we're gonna be
we're gonna maneuver faster than you
we're gonna
walk further than you we're gonna keep
working while you're resting
like though we're gonna keep our weapons
clean like all those things like that's
how you win yeah and all those things
have to do with morale